Great, we've learned so
much about efficiency.
When you look at two pieces of code you
can maybe tell which one is going to be
faster and
which one is going to be slower, but
how do we say definitively which one
is faster and which one is slower, and
how do we communicate that with our
coworkers and the people around us?
We can describe efficiency of code
with something called Big O Notation.
The name is odd if you're hearing it for
the first time but
it turns out to be a very
straightforward name.
Every time you use this notation you
literally write a capital letter O,
parentheses and some algebraic
expression inside the parentheses.
This is the algebraic expression is
always going to be a mathematical
function of the variable n, and
such as some of these examples.
As you can see, these all contain
algebraic expressions with the letter n.
The only exception is
this guy right here.
Yes the number one still counts.
It's just another way to rate 0n + 1,
so this is a value we can still use.
So what does the algebraic
expression mean in this case?
Well n represents the length
of an input to your function.
Let's say you received a secret coded
message from one of your friends and
a cipher that tells you
which letter maps to what.
You want to automatically
decode the coded messages
with the cipher your friend gave you, so
you write some pseudocode to
figure out how you can do that.
You take a string input,
you iterate through it and
change each letter based on the cipher,
and then you output a new message.
The pseudocode shows you what
it might actually look like.
Okay.
So
to get a sense of the time efficiency,
we're just going to count
up the number of lines.
Creating an output string and
returning an output string
each only need to happen once
every time the function is run.
To represent that, we can go ahead and
add a 2 to our efficiency.
Now both lines inside the for
loop have to get run for
every letter in the input.
For those we can add a 2n since 2
is the number of letters in our
input string and we have two lines
that need to get run for each one.
Hopefully, the way we count up lines and
turn it into something in Big O notation
is starting to make sense to you.
Let's take a look at some examples.
If our input string had ten letters, the
calculation would look something like
this and
we would end up with the value 22.
To get the actual efficiency,
you can multiply 22 times
the amount of time it takes for your
computer to run one line of of code.
If the input string was 1 million
you would have to multiply 2 million
times the amount of time it takes for
your computer to do a computation.
There you go,
looks like you've got the basics down.